le 20 février donc comme on le voyait
spectacle du jeune le bouchât mais il ya
50 ans les beterz débarqué en amérique
du nord avec un son look et des chansons
qu'elle ait changé le monde comme nous
le dit john napier washington un demi
siècle depuis l'arrivée spectaculaire
sur le nouveau continent de ses quatre
anglais y ayez un peu trop décontractés
pour l'époque
l'amérique pudique et bien pensante se
méfie de ces étrangers qui font craquer
les filles c'est d'abord aux aides sans
nos veines show à new york que les
beatles chanteront un de leurs plus
grands succès
une chanson écrite dans le sous-sol
d'une copine à londres
l'invasion britannique commence à la
conquête du monde par les beats aux la
grande séduction a commencé à new york
et à washington raconte le photographe
mike mitchell
il avait 18 ans à l'époque une caméra et
des tonnes d'énergie
c'est ici dans cette salle de spectacles
délabré qu'on appelait autrefois le
colisée de washington qu'a eu lieu le
premier concert des beatles en amérique
du nord
une révolution musicale inoubliable
et puis crier si fort qu'on entendait à
peine la musique dit il n'empêche
mike mitchell photographe pigiste a pris
des centaines de photos ce jour n'a à
voir des clichés qui ont pris de la
valeur au fil des décennies ailleurs
près d'un demi siècle après le concert
il a touché plus de 350 mille dollars
lors d'une vente aux enchères chez
christie's
des photos qui valent de l'or la
beatlemania façon 21e siècle ici joyce
les pieux radio-canada washington
nous aurons
le père
quand même